that's not the plan
um you when you were in car what were
you locked up for if you don't mind me
asking
um
but you're out yeah
congratulations yeah
um going through something like that
where you might like lose your freedom
does it kind of
you know make you appreciate
life a little bit more does it kind of
change the way you look at certain [__]
because like I can only imagine you know
your life might be over if it goes the
other way like uh I make you appreciate
a lot of [__] though
right yeah so you appreciate everything
we appreciate the food especially when
you see what the [__] they feed because
like we always hear people like make
their own spread and [__] in prison
right like you'll get your own [__] and
make it but like the actual food that
they give you is terrible right yeah
[__] look like okay
but I've seen like also videos where
people are making like Hibachi Benihana
type [__] this is down the road yeah
this news already don't call time like
them [__] you know what I'm saying
when [__] in the county today no
County Jail there's not too much you
could do right because you're not you're
not cool but you're right [__] Ain't
just gonna be cooking Hibachi right no
no calories
[__] I could get something about you
like the real thing before a [__]
cookie
what is
did you learn how to whip up a nasty
like a good spread in jail yeah what are
you putting in the spread
cooler Kool-Aid in the spread
all right bro you miss everything up all
this [__] go together
it don't matter is it ramen noodles
involved with the Kool-Aid what I'm
losing while every time with every meal
in them
do you find yourself
eating spread still because I have
homies who did a lot of time and they
get out and I'll go to their house I'm
gonna make a packet and they're still
eating like they're in jail yes because
they're like bro it's good what do you
want from me like it's good and it's
cheap
a pocket yeah so this is because you put
it in a bag right yeah and you just whip
it up and then no this this should take
more than just whip it up I'm good
um
all right for you man obviously
you got a big show I said Thursday in LA
doing the Nobles a big deal man that's a
that's a venue that a lot of people have
blessed on their way up you know what
I'm saying
um do you get nervous when you got a big
show like that to see you like La it's a
little different from being in a I mean
I just did break that bad
which obviously is crazy but it's home
you know what I mean I mean yeah I mean
[__] 21 he he headlined that too yeah
yeah but I don't think I'm sure you do
this so I can't really say but I'm gonna
be nervous I'd be happy as hell oh good
how was Birthday Bash that [__] was lit
I fought with it did you grow up like
going to any of the other birthday
bashes
that was my first time going
coming from Atlanta
do you automatically adopt the sports
teams
like are you a Hawks fan
I'm full with all teams and I just know
that's uh are you more like a players
guy like you're familiar for the player
before a team so who your favorite
players right now
suited up on 2K
I mean and also real life yeah but you
know I planning on 2K let me go crazy
he's really good on 2K I heard he's good
on Call of Duty too
um
[Music]
I feel like driving rain is going to end
up I feel like Nudy's gonna end up
signing John Moran before it's all said
and done you know what I mean yeah man
if you come over come on
yeah I think you know who else is a good
rapper slash Ballers uh miles Bridges
miles Bridge is a solid
he's not bad he's not bad you know also
probably could use a record I think he
signed a Sada baby so I guess he's
already gotten taken up you know so you
like drama are you a Trey young guy
Katie Carrie Luca Lucas he's gold piece
bro yeah who is the goat
[Music]
well I mean that's unfortunate that
you're not that smart
if you want huh you want I thought he
got swept he's to go I mean he's 40.
what's up saying that's uh I think
LeBron might have a child older than you
I could be wrong but you do
what I mean I'm just saying he's like an
old man he's been doing it so long
foreign
is the goat no what about Jordan but you
have never seen Michael Jordan play
basketball so I guess we really can't
even say that right you saw him on
YouTube
okay so who's your goat
me I should have been putting me down
NBA years ago
you're the goat yeah yeah hmm I'm trying
to think since you've been like
um
oh I'm it's probably for your generation
like low-key it's probably honest
oh yeah
yeah
Giannis is probably in the last 10 years
you know it's probably honest you know
probably the best player the last decade
or so what do you think about Nicola
jokic that big goofy white man
be hard too yeah it's hard to stop him
yeah good job yeah shout out to John man
John's gotta [__] stay off Instagram
you gotta take take take his IG live
away and he'll be all right